let's hear from some people in the
audience because of the shortened
Thanksgiving week we're doing our calls
today instead of on the Friday show we
take calls via Discord at
davidpakman.com
slash Discord let's first today speak
with Gary from California Gary you're on
the air what's going on
hmm
Gary
from California you're on the air
Gary we're hearing some pops coming from
you are you able to unmute and talk to
me
uh yeah can you hear it yes I can what's
going on
um okay uh sorry if there's stuff in the
background but I'm kind of new to the
whole politics thing I was wondering if
there's any primer that I can read that
would get me into like
uh social democracy or Keynesian
economic theory
oh uh okay so wow um yes there are tons
of books on those topics I I don't I
don't know that I have specific
recommendations but I as a great place
to start
um go to the Wiki page for any of these
topics and I'm I know anybody can edit
Wiki so before everybody jumps down my
throat go down to the sources where you
will see Source materials and that's
always a great place to start a lot of
these Wiki Pages have dozens or even
hundreds of references that include
articles and books that you can read
that's a good place to start I I don't
know of any specific book on social
democracy necessarily uh but that that's
where I would recommend you start
all right thank you all right Gary from
California uh thanks very very much for
the uh call let's continue let's go next
to Vince from Wisconsin Vince you're on
the air
um can you hear me yes I can
oh great uh how you doing David I'm
doing well thanks Vince
all right so I just had two questions I
had a brief question and a longer
question all right and my longer
question is uh what are your thoughts on
attorney general Garland's performance
so far I don't know that he's done
enough one way or the other to really
evaluate his performance
um he has put out some memos memoranda
as we might call them
um saying that uh he's going to be
looking into this or or exploring that
uh I just don't think we have enough
data points I mean he's been in his job
months and I I don't know that I have
anything substantive to say about his
performance this way at this point in
time
yeah he seems pretty milk toast to me I
mean he's he's not he's refused to he's
still sitting on uh charges for uh
obstruction of justice charges for Trump
representing him for God's sake in that
lawsuit uh I believe it's EG and Carol
is your name who accuse him of rape yeah
and uh defamation lawsuit I mean that's
going forward as far as I know
oh really yeah good that's good are you
rolling dice in the background by the
way
sorry about the noise but my uh my
second question is uh would you consider
interviewing Brian Tyler Cohen at any
point
um I I mean I don't know that it's for
our show usually we don't interview
people who just have like other channels
like mine but I would definitely do a
collaboration with him of some kind like
on a live stream I think it'd be a
better fit for that but like on our show
you know I don't tend to interview like
Sam cedar or Faron cousins or that type
of thing on the podcast but I would do a
collaboration with him for sure
okay all right thanks David all right my
pleasure thanks for the call very much
appreciate it one of our sponsors is
blinkist who's been supporting the David
Pacman show longer than any other
sponsor blinkist is the app that lets
you listen to or read an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes
blinkist is the way to absorb those
books you can't make time for blinkist
takes top non-fiction titles pulls out
the book's key takeaways and insights
and gives it to you in the form of a
text or audio explainer that you can
consume in 15 minutes with blinkist now
you actually do have time to learn about
all the things you've been wanting to
tackle on the blinkist app I just
listened to this is your mind on Plants
by the great Michael pollen super
interesting the history of caffeine and
so many other things blinkist has you
covered on podcasts too blinkist takes
long episodes of popular podcasts and
distills them into audio you can listen
to in 15 minutes with blinkist you can
become knowledgeable about so many
different things you can have
conversations with people about more
topics blinkist makes you more
well-rounded tribe link is for free and
get 25 off a subscription go to
blinkist.com
davidpackman the link is down below